thank you
[Music]
whoa whoa there is a a question that was
asked on am I
uh that actually made the news somehow
and that's what the news is reporting
I thought it'd be fun to have the
careful boys answer this question so a
Reddit user apps if she was wrong to
wear a colossally large engagement ring
to a relative's engagement party oh to
another engagement party to find
colossally large he's a big boy but is
that her true engagement ring yes wait
what are the rules of engagement are you
not allowed to wear engagement rings to
other people
I don't know it's not a rule I mean you
guys know you guys are the most married
ones you guys know how like you guys
know how like we're just guys being
dudes and dudes being Bros right yeah
and then we get in the car and then our
chick's like I can't [ __ ] believe
that [ __ ] you knew better and I'm like
what yeah yeah yeah juicy Stacy it's my
engagement party and that [ __ ] [ __ ]
comes here with a rhinestone the size of
Mount much more can you [ __ ] believe
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah we're demonetized
again
that's true because you're not supposed
to wear white gown to wedding right yeah
well that one's pretty no yeah
already engaged then I think it's fair
game you're win your engagement ring
anyway but you wear that all the time
but if it's a surprise like uh like it's
that new person's engagement ring and
then you're like not engaged yet and you
show up with a big ass Rock like
surprise I'm actually engaged too and
you steal the Thunder if you present it
and steal the Thunder that's [ __ ] up
going like this and [ __ ] you're just
like oh it's such a itchy day oh my God
I didn't know you're getting engaged too
look at mine but isn't this like okay
and again as a dude you know as a dude
being a bro
like when Tom Brady wins a Super Bowl he
gets to bring all his old Rings like the
[ __ ] Super Bowl like where they're
getting their new rings and like some
new players just got their first ring
but Tom Brady's got [ __ ] ice on both
hands Super Bowl rings you're not
necessarily wearing every day though we
gotta find the man equivalent to this
like full paw oh yeah what is the
equivalent to in a game well something
that happened at my wedding
well that I didn't I had no idea about
but it made sense afterward was um one
of Nikki's bridesmaids showed up with
blue hair
and like I didn't know that that's like
a [ __ ] did you fight her okay I'm
supposed to fight oh with hair because
that's like super loud and it's gonna
take away from like the entire photos
and the Trinkets and then there's a
color cord right it may come in with
blue hair yeah so then that's [ __ ] up
Mickey's matron of honor was [ __ ]
livid when she showed up and I don't
even know this [ __ ] is a [ __ ] thing
yeah which is like [ __ ] we need to get
the memo that this was an Avatar theme
because
um a wedding is a straight up event
right like you pick flowers you pick the
tablecloth like everything is colored
very coordinated so it comes off selfish
branded it's everything that's [ __ ]
you're choosing pantones and [ __ ]
because in the pictures that's gonna
look stupid yeah someone comes complete
opposite you're [ __ ] the whole and
was that like a brand new hair dude like
or they weren't rocking it prior it was
brand new yeah that's stupid that's like
a groom's in bringing a beer hat yeah
that's kind of that's pretty sick that's
kind of sick though
you know yeah yeah you gotta get his
drink so that what that sounds like is
dudes are just cooler than chicks
because we don't really honestly I mean
we're just trying to be Bros and I do it
live
okay so let me turn the page a little
bit right so now you guys know a little
bit about about the sorcery prep can you
read it so everybody already knew I was
engaged this the person says okay but
this was the first time they'd seen the
ring in person so at the start of the
party everyone gathered around
interested in seeing this [ __ ]
movement yeah that's not her fault also
she stole a little bit of a spot I mean
you know the other girl what about the
other girl does she have an engagement
ring yet they do yeah so that's her
engagement party yeah so yeah she has an
engagement ring and like everyone's
coming together to like celebrate their
engagement I mean she's still in a
little bit of Spotlight if like it comes
to her even though it's organic She's
Gotta even if people are like wanting to
be like oh no it's not my party run I'll
show you later I got I got one for you I
got one that's all right so all right
let's say we're all going to Steve's
birthday party and we all know the
secret is Nikki was like yo I got this
[ __ ] big nut lifted truck for Steve
but then you guys also know that I just
got a new truck but you didn't see it
yet you didn't see it yet but I rolled
up to the party and then you got but
then we do the surprise whoa that's
[ __ ] 60 and then I come up late and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] that shit's
[ __ ] sick Joe and then they look at
my car too oh yeah and then they look at
his car they go look at my car then they
go actually Joe's is kind of cool let me
just no but these guys are gonna be like
racist that's it I think dudes dudes are
better like having like guys like having
all the guys having the cool same [ __ ]
yeah plus if you have like a decal of
that kid with like an Anarchy sweater
and he's like pissing on like the
American flag and I'm like yo where'd
you get that thing I uh you know I
wouldn't be like what that's [ __ ] up
you got the sick decal I'd be like yo
where'd you get that dude because you
know how like there's that joke where if
got two guys wear the same outfit at a
party they're like complete strangers
and they're like brothers right and then
like yeah and when girls do that they're
like you [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
they're always like I know I know
they're embarrassed [ __ ] got this in
the same [ __ ] website these are just
better I think
that's what I keep proving all of us as
a group blanket statement sure we just
don't care that much is the whole thing
I'm finding I think it I I think you
know what it is it's the it's the moment
stealing the Thunder stealing yeah yeah
hey but here's the thing though she's
the the girl that's writing this is the
one with the bigger ring right with the
bigger correct yeah because it's and
there were comparisons being made
throughout the party right where it's
like it's like hey hey hey you know and
like she is a smaller rock is this a
humble
Brandis yeah it's like like what I
notice is girls are so considerate that
if you're not considerate enough they
think you're a [ __ ] talking [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's true
all of us understand that we're mindless
and it's not harmful intent we just
stupid we're stupid we come in Thunder
steel or whatever like no one's like
you're stupid malicious [ __ ] you
try to steal this intentionally because
you're a friend of me like no one says
that they go
you you didn't tell me you had a new car
yeah and then when you leave the room
but whereas guys like Bart says we're
stupid dogs like if I got a problem with
Anthony I'm like
that's done it's squashed it's like more
it's more like she just had an
opportunity to be extra extra cool and
just didn't take it that's it all these
it's not actually the cool guy I believe
you oh yeah that's it showed up at the
party like that right and that they go
where is it I heard you got engaged oh I
just left it at home right it's not
about me tonight oh exactly yeah that
was so cool Ultra humble yeah but but
then you know women don't do that a lot
where she's like she's like like
purposely like can I see your engagement
ring like that I'm telling you right now
when girls get burnt when they're just
engaged they're [ __ ] staring at that
[ __ ] in every version of lighting
they're very conscious when they put
that on if it's a new ring like with
their outfit they're very conscious so
if they're gonna show up to a party they
made conscious choices to wear that to
the party knowing scenarios playing
scenarios in their head that might have
happened I guarantee you that dude I
remember too because like when I gave
Nick your engagement ring I was a little
worried after because she kept looking
at her
I guess a little materialistic
you can't insecure about your rings
yeah yeah yeah
I think it's easier being a stupid dog I
think yeah yeah it is and wanting to run
as a pack is cool too but I want to know
what
what the equivalent is because
Big Thunder Steel
like there is it happened the guys with
the rice Rockets
but even those guys are rolling in packs
of like 20s yeah right like they're
still camaraderie there and they're
still but they're still male competition
you know what I mean like thunder
stealing like moments like oh yeah
pulling out a valley and just revving
your engine as hard as possible to like
exit at like 60 miles an hour in a
parking spot like but then you have to
break it goes and you like have to turn
right real quick it's like it's a little
bit of like unnecessary
yeah there's a steel with strangers
right like you drive up to a restaurant
you're like you're like I'm so [ __ ]
cool yeah
one of my favorite parts of this too is
they they rub it in a little bit they
say um and it's like you know they know
I didn't do it deliberately
um so I can see where this other
person's coming from since everyone
preferred my ring to hers
she'd be a messy but I think she's an
[ __ ] she's an [ __ ]
humble bragging [ __ ] the post is messy
the post exists is just another chance
to go hey my Ring's [ __ ] huge guys
yeah yeah I'm sorry mine's five carrots
she also said she also said that given
my ring is quite unique I should have
considered it would draw attention what
kind of ring does she got let me see I
want a little Shape of My Heart yeah I
want to see the Rings
[Laughter]
nine minutes
Mark just tried to cut the footage
it spells we're just stupid dogs
like the energy
Matt she'd be investing by making this
post yeah yeah you can tell you could
tell she's like no I'm not doing
anything she wants to floss yeah a
little bit more yeah she didn't get
enough at the party it's like it's like
it's such a validation thing like it's
like please please confirm me that I'm
right right if Rings went the other
direction and guys got him you'd be like
yo yours is [ __ ] huge it's way better
than mine baby how come you don't treat
me like that because I remember when
that's what cool dude though so in the
YouTube space Tim was also one of the
first ones he like married non-self yeah
and I remember when he told us how much
he spent on cheetah's ring it was crazy
but I never felt any of the dudes ever
go like weird I should [ __ ] spent
more it was just like what do you spend
that much that's [ __ ] crazy that's
dope yeah it's tight yeah well I feel
like our group would be like you didn't
spend nothing
that's a deal
because I feel like that's why I'm so
impressed with you Bart I feel like
these kind of dudes do exist that are
more like yo they Imagine This Moment
and whatever and we call them [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude yeah we do yeah we do like
I don't know how you edits I saw you
edit I don't have I don't have it
started with the F at first
I'm saying I'm telling you and as soon
as I smell that they have this kind of
insecurity or like whatever on them I'm
like you can't be my friend I don't like
people like you I really don't man
because I know that they're never
secretly a true human being and they're
always playing a [ __ ] game and
they're they're like they don't matter
they're kind of snaky like I don't like
that [ __ ] dude the [ __ ] lizards yeah
yeah like like the secret competition
type dudes yeah and they those dudes do
exist because they're like oh I wanted
to be the leader and I wanted to do this
and then it's like man [ __ ] you you
weren't my friend authentically you were
always competing with me when and like
all that stuff like you they exist out
there you know what Nikki taught me
about this it's usually Leo guys really
real is it is it Leo Rising no dudes bro
oh Leo dude he's got a whole [ __ ]
Asian diaspora he's talking about my my
best friend was it Leo dude is this with
uh
Korean Leo Korea
really steroids of the worst dude I
don't know why but thumbs down
[Music]